hey everybody welcome to pub G Mondays I
am NOT Mike Marty you're not no Mike
Mike is dead I don't know I'm not we're
okay
I mean I think a lot of people would
hope that after seeing the reboot really
I thought it was good I thought I was
good too
yeah hey everybody welcome to pub Monday
pub G Monday is that what you guys call
it
I'll watch your kind of it's like the
unofficial name okay cool
we're gonna watch Jake play some pub G I
can't play because my laptop so if
you've been watching these past couple
weeks both Mike and Ivan plank together
unfortunately he has the laptop with him
because he's been playing a game and
he's not here today so Jean Luc's just
gonna provide commentary tell me to duck
when I need to do actually John Luke is
gonna control the mouse and I'm gonna
call it this is how we're gonna play all
right I'm just kidding this is a
sensitivity it's a bit low for me
we'll do it well yeah it is that's a bit
high now okay there we go
all right let's get let's get weapons
mike has died rest in peace rest in
peace Mike I feel the chicken dinner
coming tonight oh man I pick up I sure
hope so
oh I have to pick okay find a grenade
grenade pick up the grenade all that guy
took it
grab the do we have no ammo dang it we
should got practicing
let's get that chicken dinner ole Mike
is gone absolutely and then we'll shut
it down right we don't need a yeah you
have to cancel hug G Mondays alright why
isn't it started yet
there it is I wrote it going I don't
think I can do that oh we should try for
one okay we'll do one well the first one
okay all right okay decide where we're
gonna go school okay all right this
quick
so you're just joining John Luke is
controlling the mouse I'm controlling
the keyboard we're gonna see how this
goes all right let me a job we're gonna
be my land kind of far okay and I'll
hold forward you just need to look up
see if anyone else gets there I'm
holding alt if you want to look around I
actually did not know that I don't see
anyone so far all right
letting go of alt yeah it's it's always
weird when you've land in the school and
it's empty there's got to be someone I'm
holding alt again if you look around
again Oh got one guy he's going for it
all right getting some people we're
gonna land just outside of the school I
think we're going after running ha ha
dang it what is the name of this game
this is pub G battle or yeah player
unknowns battlegrounds pub G as people
call it ok all right holding shift going
that way we going into that building
mm-hmm
actually we're in check the little shed
pool shed ok real quick oh there's
someone right there grabbing up the
shotgun pick up the shirt
reload it reload ammo reload it reload
it reload reload it nope that didn't
work I thought I'd picked up the ammo ok
starting off great
Oh
stay free Jake
okay this one's for real all right you
should try another one though at some
point sure sure we could periodically
try that again let's get a real I want
to see you in action
yeah that gun oh man that sounds good
this goes really good the only issue
with it is that if you don't find an
extended mag it is like look at this oh
can I shoot that's it so one time I mean
a friend we went to like a parachute
drop found it and we're like oh shoot
there's there's a car coming so we're
like running and we're like we got to go
for they said we got to go for the
selfie and I dive over it and my friends
like dude what are you doing like they
can see you and I turn around and they
totally don't see us they you're like
looking at the box and I'm like dude I
don't think they saw us even though like
they should have seen us and so I I just
like a but I just murder both of them
with it and I'm like alright cool we did
it nice I I almost never go for boxes
but I ran for one last night and like I
got a bunch of good stuff out of it but
then someone rolled up and killed me
right after yeah so yeah that one was a
hot zone because then a two more group
showed up from opposite ends and we were
in the middle we're like hums we will
actually get away though man that was
actually a really close match
alright I I typically don't go for those
just because I feel like even though
there's a really good loot in there
unless it's kind of like a throwaway
game or it's early in the game and it's
near me just cuz even if there is good
Luton there I feel like being smart and
how you like weapons are gonna isn't how
you win this game I mean having a good
weapon helps but like what's very
important is positioning I think and
figure out where in the circle you
should be yeah someone says what beast
of a computer you guys running the
mursaat pub G run this smooth well it's
an alien where I think it's got a tenon
it's a 1080 has it's got 1080 in it
so that's probably why uh you know go to
the quarry Corey has some hello hell's
gate or I could just Landon
is nya um yeah man whatever he wants nya
now cuz I already passed this one yeah
all late now what never goes to that in
that mountain hill I landed there once
and the only time I've ever seen someone
else dropped there was when I landed
there and they killed me but yeah no one
no one typically goes there there's like
there's decent stuff up there people are
talking about this game isn't
graphically demanding so you wouldn't
think it but it does actually run kind
of poor like I have a 1070 at home and I
have to turn a bunch of settings down to
get it to run
yeah it's just not optimized yet I mean
the game is in early access so that's
definitely something I'd like to see
them ironed out because I look at it
visually and I'm like I should be able
to run this IMAX oh that's no problem
anywhere around ooh
chayo 5 says you guys are my favorite
game spotters after old wire really oh
wow Wow I'll take that no I better not
let you down I better win this game huh
I'm not gonna win
Payton ford says his run couldn't be
worse than the last one that's true I
want blood
grenade so I need
I've never gotten a grenade killing this
game I think I've ever even bothered to
throw a grenade
i I mean I've killed teammates with a
grenade not on purpose
I didn't realize it was when I first
started playing I didn't realize you
pulled a pin when you rear it back uh
[Music]
hells gate says was the main point in
this game uh to be the last person alive
get that chicken dinner already 20 dead
Wow
okay like I always think how insane it
is that already twenty people are dead
but then if you think about it like
almost every like almost everyone like
right when they land they they encounter
someone right so someone's got to die
right there's very much like a the
beginnings pretty rough and then it kind
of dies down for a bit in the middle a
lot of people trying to avoid each other
I got an A K which is nice I thought I
had a helmet I have one now I guess
alright I have to turn the sound up a
little bit on this or maybe on there I
can hardly hear my own footsteps now I
can hear all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
kind of ride this cuz once it once the
gunshots start oh yeah
gets loud oh okay yeah I'll take that
that's the one home I have a like a
slider where I can adjust the volume
really easily and that's nice because
I'll crank it up when it's quiet and I
need to be able to hear footsteps but
then when the shooting starts all right
crank it back down because Oh loud yes
it does it's loud
ben says he thinks he's gotten more
kills in this game blowing up cars next
to people than with grenades I've never
even thought of that it's a strategy man
ooh
we're gonna go into the SS this this
isn't that good not like it's so nice to
have it's nice to have it's not that
great what I'm gonna do is if I find a
scope which it doesn't look like I will
I'll take the ball put that on the other
m16 or a K I tried the VSS and take the
m16 good wants to know who's the best
pop G player in the office well
internationally
it's definitely Dave Dave you think Dave
I haven't seen him play much he's really
good um however here it's probably Mike
probably yeah I was gonna say you were
my mostly cuz you guys just play the
most yeah I was looking at my how long
I've played I forgot where it's in here
yeah yeah I mean I've I was I've played
120 hours of this game I think which is
more than I've ever played or the more
that I've played a multiplayer game
since like call of duty modern warfare 2
damn how many hours did you say 120 whoa
yeah that's a lot I think 30 hours of
that is a fluke like I think I left them
running all right weekend one time still
a lot though so many hours that's good
yeah I uh
what's a circle like we're pretty good
I might just keep checking these
building yeah camp it out
yeah that's hello no thanks I feel like
I need I need I need a vest it'd be nice
to get a better better helmet - what's
your favorite place to drop my favorite
place to drop is on the south side of
Rock okay because a lot of people drop
in Rostock not a lot of people drop on
the south side for some reason and
that's the elevated side and usually
there's enough buildings up there for
like a team of two to get decently armed
not like great you're definitely have to
go into town but it's good to drop there
look around see more landing day if
there is anyone who lands there
normally they forget about you and
they're just easy kills
Coop's is damn this ain't the Witcher I
think in reference to your your hours
I have more hours in this than I do or
on steam I have more hours on this than
I do on The Witcher on steam but if you
and you like my god right
no PS ps4 never come see when the
Witcher came out everyone I've only
played like 60 hours Hell's Gate I am
John Luke and this is Jake we're playing
some hot pub G right now face mask
[Music]
cowboy wants to know how many times have
you won five for four or five I've won
one since squad one since solo twice and
do it so that is four I have I've yet to
win I've gotten really close a couple
times though so I'm itching I've taken a
break from this and playing lost platoon
two but I do eventually want to get back
to this mag yeah
game is hard like if like for someone
like I feel like there's two two kinds
of people who played us they're the
people who are really really good and
like winning comes down the skill and
there are people who aren't so good
probably like me and winning comes down
to luck right like not not entirely luck
right like it like you definitely like I
have to beat out like fire fights and
stuff like it takes skill yeah but
sometimes like you win or lose just
depending on where you land what you get
like who you run into what you run into
like if you find a vehicle but that's
not to say it's all like determined by
luck right like I mean like my first win
or my my solo win like I think I got
like five five or six kills which I
think it's pretty decent for when I see
a lot of people on Twitter posting like
I got a win and they got like one or two
kills yeah I got a couple questions here
someone's asking about how graphically
good the game looks and is a
disadvantage to term for graphics it is
once your frame rate starts to dip so
typically I'll kind of like turn off
certain settings you want to always have
like the kind of put the shadow is on
medium stuff like that but you want like
the the field of view to be as high as
possible so you can see people Oh goo
gives me a shout out for my a sonic
video Thank You goob yeah appreciate you
watching the whole thing I was actually
impressed like I got a couple people who
were like 50 minutes I am watching all
that which was like that's totally fair
oh dude you are is some [ __ ] going on
I'd let it play out yeah actually a lot
of people watched all all the way
through which is really nice
Lewis asks are you hype for the Xbox
version also do you think they'll ever
make it pay to win no I do not think
they'll make it pay to win
yeah no isn't I don't think I'm hyped
for the Xbox for you yeah I am too
that'll be cool but I do not think they
will ever make it pay to win kind of a
seeing interview with it would break the
game yeah break the game and see
interviews with
mr. player unknown himself the way he
kind of talks about his vision for this
game I don't think he would ever want to
make this have any sort of like played
away in microtransactions or anything
like that I I wouldn't be surprised if
there's microtransactions to open to get
for those boxes or those boxes right
just cosmetic I think the only thing
that's not cosmetic is something you
start out with and it's the pistol
holster which lets you carry more Oh
Hell's Gate I am Jake I'm sorry I'm John
Luke sure let's go with that
there it is psycho for it ooh that's far
away dude that is far I'm not going for
it the cardia I haven't seen one I can't
oh god kill him yeah
nice the streets run red oh [ __ ] there's
another guy oh he's he's got no pants
I'm gonna let him run forget him
it was a warning shot has already been
checked I'm gonna go to the roof see if
I can get some good sight or maybe not
the roof just someone asked over there
any sonic fans here and Ben replied I
like City escape he's a City escape fan
I know I'm a city escape man me too
follow me set me free that's how it goes
right exactly and we will escape from
this I'll make it through something mmm
follow me yeah I did the video is very
informational so I don't really get much
into like my personal opinion because
it's just that kind of video but yeah
playing through those old games again I
didn't think Sonic Adventure 2 held up
particularly well I don't think it does
at all that was one of my favorite game
I was a kid but but the that first level
is still pretty fun like the city escape
is I think that's when a lot of people
talk about how much they're like oh I
love Sonic I think a lot of them think
about levels like City escape those were
and I think they forget that you also
have to do the tails mech shooting
sequences which are just dull and the
knuckles shows renting sequences which
are just frustrating yeah cityscapes
still cool though
man I didn't even loop that guy I'm
afraid to look yeah actually I think
Sonic Generations is one of the best
Sonic games because they just take all
the best levels from every Sonic game
and they get a whole video game oh oh
stop
Oh God oh you had no idea that poor men
slowly Park up here that's what I like
this gun though cuz silencers are so
good and yeah yeah
but I mean even if I even if that wasn't
silenced I don't think you would have
seen me it happened too fast they call
me the Viper in this game John Luke what
do they call Mike the hippopotamus
there's a Potamus actually hippopotamus
it scary they call Mike I don't know
dead that's what they call Mike hahaha
DK says where's Michael my Hardy so uh
where where is he actually he had a an
appointment of some sort it was supposed
to be at 9:00 and as well as was 20
minutes long but it took too long I
guess so he couldn't make it in time
yeah normally we try to both play
however he also has the laptop that we
normally use so it's just me playing on
a table not able to play today just kind
of a bummer it's probably better for you
got well actually I don't know I think
it's more entertaining to watch the goop
fly but the good thing about it is that
if I die then it will just go right to
the next game exactly as much waiting
around yeah and I can be here talking to
the chat which I assume you guys weren't
really able to look at chat much I'm
gonna go leave that guy it's probably
this is gonna be the death of me this is
always the death you could also you can
also take his car as well I could I'm
gonna wait see where the circle goes
though that's not a good point
a pan what's your favorite weapon oh no
um I really like the SKS all the
graphics I graphics I take the
holographic sight take that do you have
the level 2 backpack No
level 2 police vest oh that's broken
though if you want that yeah it's almost
broken so it protects you the same
amount it just like breaks quicker oh
this guy has an SKS oh oh I don't know
that VSS was pretty handy and I've got
that a K which I can switch I probably
won't take that I'm gonna die because
I'm spending too much time here okay
oh girl those energy drinks and [ __ ]
well okay oh yeah grab that stuff all
right there you go oh dude oh no up with
my helmet oh yeah go getting some uh
some black here from the server that's
no good I would wait this out yeah I'm
getting high how did you do when he
first played pub G when I first played
pub G I died almost right away yeah I
mean I remember my first game I jumped
into a house didn't understand like
realize that you have to find weapons
like ran inside couldn't find any
weapons and a guy just shot me I last
like 30 seconds yeah my first couple
matches I was playing with a friend who
wasn't playing for a bit so he was kind
of guiding me through it so it was a lot
of me just sort of following him you
know learning kind of the rules and how
to play this game I would always be like
looking the same direction he'd always
be like no you're supposed to cover our
six you don't never look in the same
direction I'm looking and was like oh
okay this is one of those games it
definitely is like it's it's you have to
do a bunch of tactics that like me and
my friends are doing games you didn't
need to do like we used to play like
battlefield floral or battlefield 3 and
company's stuff all the time I'm like
yes playing tactically like definitely
helps but when it comes down to it like
you don't have to you you and your team
can just eff off and or your squad and
like you'll be fine like maybe you won't
do as well but this game like actually
calling out enemies actually sticking as
a group actually covering sixes yeah
using phrases like cover my six is yeah
it's like legitimately helps you win
games unless you're playing by yourself
in which case you just wait until guys
and buggies drive up and you just pop
them in the head but I will do that for
much longer
only 34 left sending out the number hang
I don't even know if it's worth taking
this at this point well we want to see
where that circle once we're done stop
all right I got a bit of a ways to
travel I would maybe take that buggy
then yeah then I'm gonna aim for up here
which way did the plane go went down
this way right there's like no good way
to come about this
that's know I think it went up it did I
think there's no good way except getting
a boat and maybe maybe getting a boat's
not a bet now I don't want to just hang
out in the water this will probably be
the definite
let me get out of this city first though
house gate says did you play call of
duty
yeah played a fair amount of call of
duty yeah I think the one I played the
most of it was modern warfare 2 & 3
being shot to do so when I played the
most I don't really like 3 where I grew
up I didn't have being shot I didn't
have high speed internet so I didn't
have it until modern warfare 3 came out
even though my peak interest in Call of
Duty was doing modern warfare 2 so I'd
have to go to friend's house and play it
I think the one I actually played online
though though I'm gonna die someone
asked why do people we pan and never use
it that is because the pan protects your
ass actually like it's on the back and
it'll actually protect you so it's a pro
strategy all right what is going on it's
it's a oh they shot out iron you'll
didn't load awesome
that was weird
are you in the circle I am in the circle
maybe head to that house
I do you want to see I'm gonna get
behind this rocking back actually maybe
I'll go here gonna heal first and then
go there let's take that pain killer
lost my helmet helmet protected me a
good thing I didn't get the other one
otherwise it would have broke and I
probably died actually I want to save it
Thank You Lee yeah yeah I would take
energy drink if you were to take any of
those yeah that's probably a better idea
of good yeah seven of those of course
I'm standing up like a [ __ ] here now
what are the different modes in this
game so you can do singles doubles and
four right yeah and all of them are the
same thing like just make it be the last
team or person standing right yeah right
now there's only one mode there's only
one map they're working on a second map
instead of won't be out for a while
though yeah there are different modes on
the test server I think you can do like
a zombies mode
I'm not entirely sure that works me
either also I don't know if I care about
that like kind of whatever like I was
there
oh wow I hope she seems really cool like
kind of inventive and they're like we've
added a zombies mode and I was like all
right well it was bound to happen I
guess I'm curious to try it like since
I've spent so much time in might as well
but I have a feeling it'll be one of
those things where it's like alright
I've played for like four hours I kind
of want to change a pace but I still
keep playing it I'll play a couple
rounds of zombies because I think the
zombies are player-controlled
too which is kind of interesting okay
man you know helmet mmm afraid of my
face mask though yeah you know much in
the way of options for how is this
dilute nope
I could go up here but I guarantee these
of already I've guaranteed oh [ __ ] I
guarantee old man well you might not
have a choice all right should I go or
should I wait uh I'm pretty close yeah
but I feel like I should at least like
go around a little bit get to a
tactically more advantageous position
like four people are survivors everyone
else is zombies
what's so philanthropy what do you know
like the point of it like do you just
need to kill all the zombies do you need
to survive a certain amount like do
zombies have respawned because I haven't
even watching these streams like all I
know is there's a zombie mode and
gunshot not at me though yeah it's not
that place you were talking about 16
left
but my Adrenaline's gonna kick in soon
unless I just up and die
any regrets about not giving this game
more coverage from earlier date yes all
the time yeah totally yeah I think we
should have jumped on a little bit
sooner we we kind of tried like we did
we did like vods and like kill montages
and stuff like that but that's not how
you show the show yes this game you
stream this game like highlights like
twitch highlights yes but like I think
like oh I bet this one's gonna be pretty
good for extra life
yeah I've for some reason I've been
thinking about extra life which I really
shouldn't because it's so far away I was
saying about like oh your life I was
like this is a good one this'll be fun
all right I know I'm being a wiener and
I'm just laying in a bush dude don't you
do it
I say win this game man what's the
funniest death you've ever had I mean I
when I pulled the pin on a grenade and I
didn't realize that when you rear it
back you pull it and I blew up me and
because we were all packed into a tiny
little building get oh yes I know any
zombie bar those can't wait for the
first person only servers yeah that'll
that's excited for that too all right
anyone coming over this hill yeah that
sounds pretty intense
don't Thanks oh [ __ ] don't run me over
this is how I died
him accidentally running like they don't
even know you're there he just was like
I'm gonna go for that bush whenever you
like I'm with a team and every was like
all right car get down everyone lays on
the grass maybe they don't see us they
run me over and that's it every single
time I'm always going to get run over
Darren's is driving me crazy with no
helmet he had to help me he lost it yeah
my helmet got shot off oh my got shot
off and he hasn't found one yet and I'm
afraid like I'm sure there's helmets in
there but I am NOT gonna go and look
alright what are we looking at Turin
BMAC says what is this channel for this
channel is the official GameSpot Channel
we stream every day well not every day
every weekday at 11 a.m.
Mondays for the last couple weeks Jake
and Mike have been streaming pub G
usually with the lobby's always on
Wednesdays on Thursdays my computer or
not Robin Peter you just do something
and then on Friday Oh
me and Joey or something I'm dead is it
free man I know I'm trying to get there
ah damn good not good enough I won't get
to eat
how long do people make custom servers I
think you can in the test yeah so
hopefully next update which is supposed
to actually come soon I think oh man all
right Bob Jones says don't get
distracted by talking that's true I know
where I'm like I'm trying to like talk
with a chat but I'm also not trying to
just I shouldn't have left I like was
worried about that open field but it
would have been safer if I waited rather
than got up and ran right he's giving
you advice to use your energy drinks and
painkillers more yeah that's true that's
a good strategy is when you're like if
you're gonna run across a field where
you know like use you can't like just
take a painkiller
also when I first played I think a lot
of people thought this but I thought
this was like the game I was like when
it counts down you just need to get as
far away from everyone as you can
oh yeah I thought that do I kind of like
how this game just like explains nothing
and just yeah I'll figure it out oh and
if they're gonna I wonder if they're
gonna add like tutorials because it's an
early access or if they're just gonna
leave it like that they'd probably like
at this point don't even need to add
yeah it's still kind of overwhelming but
it's like they they should but you're
right in that like they probably don't
there's probably like not high on their
radar of things to do or how were you
doing Corey or the popke I say Corey's
like a mini school like usually there's
a lot of people that go there but it's
not nearly as crazy
I love the school there's something
really exhilarating about just like
getting right to it I know I'm when you
when you come out on top you're like
alright I've done it yeah I I prefer
I've ever need anything I prefer to
start places where it's crazy rather
than like land in the middle of nowhere
exactly yeah I like I like sarnoff crazy
because you get that action and early
get your blood going yeah and then and
and the thing is if you die it's like I
died really early it's fine load and
operate into a new game it's not a big
deal all right man good luck there's
there are all that guys or dude just
flat flat on his face
you just gonna punch him yeah Oh God
already gunshots right yep oh god oh god
that guy's got a gun
up yep
head up head up someone landed on the
roof or no someone tried to land on the
roof huh okay three back back yeah I
grabbed back grab those grenades pistol
I'll reload dg2 it Oh God whoa whoa what
just happened
keep going up man think so I'm finished
checking these rooms you can check him
whatever else is dead it's true oh oh
God
where was that he must said most someone
must have landed on the roof
never chase him mind you dang Bob
Genesis I think quick death this match
you're correct accurate hey thought a
pop side up every time that's annoying
play all right P count two so far wait
three because we had that team but I
made it to the top ten cube do you want
to try that again yeah let me do one
more 71 [ __ ] then we'll try team again
work on my headshot punch actually we
can practice now if you want well here
all right give me with the rifle reload
man this is stuff here I'll stop moving
yeah but that's the thing it's like
you're gonna have to be like moving
there we go I mean this is blood oh [ __ ]
that's one thing I have to do I forgot
it doesn't Otto laughter like yeah nope
this was hard a thing kill cam would be
cool yeah I would like to kill cam just
so I know how I died especially in solo
like I get why you wouldn't want one in
a squad cuz that could give away the
enemy position but right solo it doesn't
matter now that's totally I guess I can
reload
damn it I thought got rid of all of
those Jean Haywood says why are there
guns already that is just like the leg
lobby area where you get to like pick up
guns and kind of practice shooting
school school do it or should I land in
these buildings
no that's the apartments I say school
over apartment
John Kraft says I love when you see
everyone parachute in yeah that's really
fun
straight down yeah right on that roof to
the depths of hell
the key to going so much lower is just
by going straight down like cuz you pull
your parachute but you still run so fast
that oh yeah hop right in there just get
right in it fall right yup nah man just
find a gun oh god I'm gonna die oh oh
yeah there's definitely a guy in there
earlier all the revolver the robber
socks I know I've got no other options
though Jesus shoot him shoot that man I
shot him I suppose I should reload
well I stayed yeah yeah he's got no way
no mo though Dan all right I'll take it
actually did he have a backpack I'm
spending way too much time on ya head up
to the second floor good idea [ __ ]
revolver Oh Oh Oh a shot head shows SK
dang well I got a grenade kill that
sweet grenade kill us I made that whole
round worth it see that's where the
school is awesome cool stuff like that
happens okay we're gonna try a team solo
I guess this is not gonna go well almost
Adam yeah how long until this is an
esport I'm at work she has a little work
hmm shoot that man all right all right
so if you missed the beginning of the
stream John Luke is controlling the
mouse I'm on keyboard so we're gonna see
how this goes
yeah this'll be uh all right grab it
grab that Uzi or something
you gotta pick it up no sorry I was
looking at chat so low do
you have to let me know what fire write
stuff on we have bullet holes in us yeah
I think I think the lack of
communication is gonna be key here yeah
we wants to do this I have no ammo
all right where are we going struck that
app uh looks like we're coming into the
from the north no yeah we're coming from
the north mm-hmm just drop right in
Severna we could go for the school again
ooh
do you wanna yeah let's do it all right
do it well actually we're gonna be kind
of wide for [ __ ] all right
all right on the jump
what part of it she can't do it while
anda
I'll just hold w's it's up to you
I'm holding all if you look around see
if anyone else is falling
one guy a couple guys it's like they're
pretty far up there we'll probably see a
lot of parachutes getting pulled all
right
maybe land in the church now the church
sucks yeah sometimes head for yeah yeah
for that red uh that one yeah one two
little three floating around outside
okay alright like I ain't is landing
over there okay head into that building
okay
yep grab that grab that Oh perfect yep
grab that Uzi ignore the reload it
switched Nick Joe first aid kit I guess
the difference okay
nothing back back back
draw get that onto that on
this is weird this is really weird yeah
this is really up these days
yep
more 9-millimeters yep we should find an
extended mag we got that what is the
flash hider that's for a arse take this
room no no all right we should get out
of here all right decent not bad not bad
this Auto yeah oh that's me okay
I'll take it I come and hand you later
try this room right here now close that
door there's a another door this is just
outside
all right okay all right Oh crappy
shotgun get there open up inventory and
you can just uh what we should have
something now I mask on all right do you
want to read a little bit shotgun yeah
yeah well while we have it you will have
um you switch weapons and supposed to be
using the scroll wheel okay you still
need to be something more [ __ ] where's
the circle
it's the north of us yeah maybe check
this building up here I'm holding alt if
you want to get a peek behind us all
right we're probably good all right
do you want to check the this story yeah
yeah no this is right here nope no I
don't know stairs behind us we can go
this is already damn it
alright hey I grabbed that there's the
roof - to the left we can check out its
right now here God dang it I guess I can
take the 9-millimeter sure all right
well we should dang it we don't want two
of these things no okay let's have a
floor we can we can check the roof yeah
let's go alright okay let's go let's get
out of here
I'm just gonna jump off the
all right we're heading we're moving uh
how about right there or about right on
here maybe up here there's some good
stuff in there we'll start here right
here yeah okay sorry pull it up again
excellently uh okay I'm just gonna hold
alt so if you ever want to look around
I don't be thinking about a great cliff
things to inventory it Auto equips yeah
that's actually something I learned
recently I've been like dragging her for
the longest time yeah a little tips like
that like the game telling you stuff
like that would be nice yeah it's like
that wouldn't be much work I there's
like a little thing pops up saying
right-click - yeah exactly
are both of you all controlling the
character yeah yeah he's he's
controlling the view and I'm controlling
the movement mouse keyboard
oh sorry right all right I'm gonna need
to readjust a little bit
hmm some so the PvP is coming to
wildlands it's wildlands just trying to
emulate this no so I looked into it and
it's a it's squad-based but there's I
don't think there's like a hundred
people I think there's only like a
couple teams I might be wrong though but
I could have sworn when I was looking
into it it seemed like that the video
that Ubisoft released seems kind of
vague nope
this place has been picked should we
look around or just leave go to the
ruins I doubt people have I heard some
gunfire oh I get I want to get in it oh
I see
well so there was a firefight we can
take now you camp at the sidelines we
still take the sights all right
pop the map
checked it yeah those are some shots
coming from the runs okay
we'll ignore that since we have a shitty
pistol or a shitty machine pistol I
switched out to auto key getting the
single yeah cuz you might on auto before
that doors closed
all right this looks good
goggles okay
keep going doors open been looted - yeah
okay
well the other ones probably looted as
well I bet right yeah
let's head it's alright I want it I want
to avoid the the ruins
hey we've survived halfway and we are
controlling different well you know we
have actually if we kill somebody that
is the real victory that is the real
victory than all the impressed
I can put weight again so you can run
faster I'll hold alt - so you can look
around
like how they had things with the camera
I always like a little details like yeah
that's nice
circles gonna close in soon I don't like
our spot at all like I spot it
we're getting near road night we can
find a vehicle we can see what drives
kinda like hoping let's get off the road
though let's not stay on it just near it
yeah
look towards the road see if there's any
uh vehicles Allison you get those up
ahead riffle boat we do is get a boat
might be good if we can find a boat I
don't dammit
then yet okay
these new cars on the other side of that
bridge I think I see a red one off yeah
I see it
which probably swim across yeah see the
circle goes to
any boats
hmm cuz a boat might be that is that one
over there maybe I can't tell because if
we have a boat we could depend on where
the circle goes we could drive in there
but now we're outside the circle or we
are outside of the circle sure though
like I don't realize oh okay they just
changed them yeah it just it just
changed um no I don't think it's a rock
yeah I don't think that's a boat out
there all right well let's try and go
for that red card then I'm holding alt
if you don't look around
it's a buggy and a red car buggy a red
car um I think we should take the buggy
and go right to Savur knee all right
let's do it or maybe like right there
actually yeah
oh we're getting shot from well oh god I
didn't mean to do that
we're screwed it's over yeah we're going
to try we're again shot from difference
damn I want to get like a real good
firefight let's let's try one more and
let's just land at the school or
somewhere where yeah I do want to I want
to see if we can at least get a kill and
that was kind of dumb because yeah and
we had like no good weapons there was
like nothing we could do there yeah
will do we'll try one more together and
then we'll do one to close out Oh grab
them all - we can grab this nice so many
headshots I'm feeling a kill coming
Jesus oh and you're moving the image
symbols and it shift and steady it and I
am unfortunately not the best aim
another week going hungry we're not done
yet goood
okay coming out of a weird angle it's
like when yeah but it should line up
with the school if we wanted to let's do
it
cube does not have a confidence no he
does not
he doesn't have confidence and yet
although in anything I do ever alright
and I'm jumping oh yeah we got a lot of
people
look forward for a little bit just so we
can get above it and now look down and
look straight down so we plummet down so
we get down quicker yeah
okay
all right I'm sure to land us on the
roof yeah all these people all right
drop down the sash yep go go down that
hatch okay
all right where are we going this way
check this room perfect guy grab it any
anyone that and then I grab that emote
hold on ambos Barry
ambos Barry okay all right set to auto
only got one magazine read that Crouch
peek in there let's do stuff dang it
thank you that first run was very good
it won't happen again
but now I'm gonna I'm gonna play by
myself again so we're gonna see how that
goes and I'm gonna goop goop don't give
me crap he had he had the mouse I had
the keyboard that was all on you man
it's all your fault I had it ooh rain so
I think what I'll do more weather
effects I would like that like snow snow
would be rad there been adding something
like time of day mostly but I think what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna try to land in
a hot zone and survive if I die I'll
just try another game and we'll try to
get a good game starting from a hot zone
and then if we make it through that hot
zone and then I die then we'll call it
if I die in a hot zone we'll try again
yeah I was thinking about um
like slight tweaks or alterations they
can do with maps and you know like that
does your map is gonna be cool but um I
was thinking like Oh what if that is
snow map and you actually make the the
circle it's like outside of the circle
is like a lizard right like a breeze to
death that'd be really cool and then you
could add like specific items for that
one where it's like okay if you happen
to have like these like a really nice
jacket or something you can survive
outside of it like slightly longer like
you'll still eventually like you can't
stay out the circle friends will die but
it's okay now gonna have a jacket on
you'll be a bit better that would be
really cool temperature stuff I'd be
super into that keeps us like the
division yeah like those kind of like
Division II style sort of like freezing
to death elements that they added in
that one's survival mode incorporating
elements like that and the pub key map
would be really really cool
and I want it to be brutal enough where
it's like we're like completely changes
the game yeah we're like you're dying
from the environment all the time just
just some slight tweaks right of that
man mainly I'm thinking like the circle
like you can give the circle like wall
for context rather than just like a
ominous blue
death field yeah that looks like it's
from Star Wars Episode one zombie happy
Oh didn't shields where you going I
don't know we've not had a successful
school around unfortunately maybe I'll
do Rostock know I'd be oh I'll be able
to make that yeah he'll make it holy
Ross Hawke
yes no one would be really cool cuz like
I think the desert one sounds really
cool in the Mediterranean one the one
supposed to be after sounds like it's
gonna be cool too but like yeah just
take advantage of those uh yeah
different effects and stuff like that I
think it would be cool if the Mirta turn
ian was a bunch of islands you know
right yeah that'd be rad and you had to
take boat to get from place to place it
sounds like the desert one is suppose to
be more suitable
oh interested eBay so yeah they released
like a map sort of a hand-drawn map of
like thinking it it'll be yeah the mayor
of Kearney once you turn into a Far Cry
location that'd be dope
shai rule hi if we're doing pretty good
I've been playing some pub G we stream
every day at 11 a.m. for those of you
wondering yeah how are you doing man
happy Monday Oh busy week so starting to
ramp up the the fall the fall season of
video games
yeah it's beginning to comas out
tomorrow right yeah
ice let me play pyre yet I'm like behind
it's too busy playing all those old
Sonic games
oops is gonna teach the Friday show oh
yeah um yeah I could probably officially
announce what we're doing with that now
you've gotta tease it and tease it so
it's gonna involve let me say it's going
to involve our brand-new video game
library that we put together
it is themed around the video game
library well normally these buildings
have better stuff but I've only found
pistols
there we go
ooh there you go oops is the library
show Reading Rainbow I remember that
I don't have I don't need that
where am I trust mokuba I think you'll
you'll enjoy it
me and Joey are pretty excited about
about the show and the people we've
pitched it to at the office I'll think
it's pretty pretty good idea so we're
hoping it turns out good
noises Lillis says hi hi Jason hi Jason
how's it going no car
what's the circle leg for it's not super
far but I definitely I'm gonna have to
move soon all right
but I haven't found that greatest stuff
yet so like no helmet that guy
actually he may sit in a chat but I know
really bugs okay all right blows that
was in your fault you had a helmet got
shot off yeah oops for days I know
all right
whoa they're not shooting behind you
dude oh man ah all right another one
yeah damn
Skyrim mods were good top five scam on I
assume that's what he's talking about
no our the show yeah hot Skyrim mods
shake it off let's go yeah come on
you got a man okay
not thinking about I don't believe me I
don't think this would make a good
eSport is it'd be really boring yeah for
like most of it yeah I don't know how
you'd make that interesting those parts
versus people camping or you know
wandering around I love the chaos of
this Lobby I know that will come up once
revenge now
okay
coming from the north
you're gonna go for the apartment gonna
go for the apartments alright
or should I just go for the school
flavor they're both high traffic zones
No
it's like I am over it straight down
all right how many people do we got
looks like one the worst is when you
land on one of the buildings without
roof access just like well these all
have roof access those two don't in the
back oh they don't I didn't know that
dang didn't land on the wrong so good ok
so at least one other guy
okay Giza is the waiting lobby reminds
me of my trip to Detroit all right
found a car in a compensator reload that
well I think that's close I need a vest
on you're the best
I need something close range to because
someone runs in here you screwed
whoa no no if I if I lose this round if
I don't get first I'm blaming that lag
right there Oh an AR suppressor perfect
Oh put that on get to the roof man I
know I should just run to the roof I'm
just gonna run to the roof I brought
that pistol
someone gets close to you
nope
sure bandages almost feel like a waste
much time helmet because it's like
usually I'm dead before I yeah there is
what we want the backpack coos press the
handgun I've gotten they are suppressing
to which nice you don't come by that
often restaurant handgun yeah all right
all right heads that Ruth
sweet oh dang oh brother energy drink
probably okay Wow dang you picked a good
now I just need a times aid scope up
here
it's gotten real quiet where's the
circle okay
how's your bad super far definitely this
looks like no one's been in this bill
our names I'm John Luke and this is Jake
and we're playing some pub G by the way
uh Jake and Mike play this every Monday
it might just happens to not be here so
I'm filling in for him all right getting
out of this building now I am all right
you got a good I'm instantly a vest
really vested by nice other than that
you're pretty set all right dude I'll be
careful just look like anyone's been in
here yeah
level 3 backpack nice yeah yes oh you're
golden another another site would be
good
I don't to get too caught up though and
missed the circle take more of that ammo
but I don't want to waste all my
inventory space with that
yeah there we go Oliver says where am i
from
I am from Vermont I'm from California
all the way from the other side of the
US all the way south a little bit just a
whole little bit south Wow damn dude you
are so sad I don't think I've ever had
that I've had more with I'm 16 but I
mean you got to start heading north yeah
I'm gonna check the roof and then I'm
gonna head over I think I'm pretty good
like it'd be nice to have a better
helmet invest but ballistic mask just in
case
the first day that gangster King says
that's way too much n16 well I don't
have a lot of car and more makeup
rooo gases are getting a 2d SXL today
Nick just got one didn't he he did it
looks it looks pretty sleek yeah if I
was to so I'm pretty happy with I have a
3ds XL but if I was to get one I
actually really like the looks of those
um they're called new 3d asses 3d asses
is what they're officially called oh is
that the one that Nick got no no and it
got the 2d s I think right oh oh yeah
yeah I then the naming so weird but they
know they're officially called like new
3ds and it's someone where you can swap
the faceplates oh ok Scott like the
Super Nintendo like buttons on it I like
the look of that one a lot like the size
of it is really really nice it feels
sleek I think that's like that's the
perfect fit for me I think that I have a
little small hand so I find the that
sells fine but I'm okay with the whole
smaller system I have the new 3ds XL I
don't think I'll ever get another 3d s
though unless mine breaks then maybe but
I don't think I'd upgrade gangsta King
says they like the look of the game in
the stream mine looks way worse that's a
prevailing theme a lot people in the
chat or commenting on how how good our
game looks and how it looks a lot worse
for everyone else that's because we're
running it in like a 1080 mic mic kept
complaining about how this game was
running last last week I don't I think
it's it's doing good the only times
we've had issues are the seem
server-side not really yeah related to
what graphical settings are you playing
at I actually do not know nope was that
a better no I've got the best back ok
but this place has been checked already
we'll be careful which makes me nervous
because I need more yeah you don't have
enough
whoever kills me is gonna have a lot of
m16 ammo techno junk says I subbed and
followed on Twitter oh thank you thank
you
appreciate that
I'm gonna wait I'm gonna hold out wait
until the circle closes in and then I'll
think about moving hmm probably moving
around too much being like - oh my god
because I imagine people might be coming
up this way after the school cat guy
says a pretty sure Jake was also on a WB
show before like Dawson's Creek or
charmed
I was I'm surprised you remember that
you look like you could be on one of
those shows you have like the nice like
pretty boy face for it thank you
I guess sort of a compliment kind of
yeah I [ __ ] hate the people on those
shows but you could be pretty good on it
I'd be the cool person on those shows oh
yeah yeah like you know the people like
I had everyone on the show except him
he's cool I'd be like no I wouldn't be
that one
I'm so antsy I want to go and move but I
know I shouldn't is this that no I have
pistol mmm I know I should I've got such
good stuff oh hi there
you gonna do it let's see what he does
he's probably gonna keep running
should I follow I shouldn't I went to so
bad though I want you so bad
I'll see where the circle goes play it
safe [ __ ] I'm gonna go this is the death
of me right here and where is this guy
how many one mores are we on gooo
Basques this is probably the last one
yeah I've survived decently long
unfortunately haven't gotten any action
yet though oh there's the action and
there's me my death shouldn't have done
it no God oh damn didn't even get to use
my stuff that sucks oh do you wanna do
one more about ten minutes I'll do it
okay I'll do one more if you insist
only if you insist goof says one more
the people have spoken
drink your I forgot I should have
drinking my energy drink I always forget
to do that one more for duo now one last
long Stevie let's do one more proper one
GameSpot's is always be boosted man it
was your mistake
yeah have a one more counter a
deathcounter and a kill counter
someone's saying those are the worst
kinds of rounds get fully kitted out and
then you just get just get shafted yeah
yep it was probably that guy shot at
probably I didn't shoot at him he would
he probably would I kept running would
have been fine have a swim to the island
could you swim back to this island yes
you can
the circle will never land on it will it
no it'll never land on it so what you
have to do is you have to land near the
coast getting a boat drive out there so
you're just doing it for funsies
basically yeah I mean I've heard there's
really good stuff out there however all
of the the tables just they're set up
but there's no weapons there's weapons
if you look around there but I was there
once with Nick and we didn't find
anything right this is a waste and then
we just turned around all right I'm
gonna land in Gatka
all right go because people like to
landing jacket big dirty shot is asking
will you guys be switching to
first-person servers wants us out you
should definitely stream stuff we will
definitely try it yeah
scroll back just to think of all those
lost on the rounds well at least one
person anyone else near you
oh yeah
oh you got four people man we're good
I'm not worried I'm very worried I'm
scared to death you were in so much
trouble see a boy
they're in trouble too though got to
think of it that way
Oh Oh sixteen already all right
why won't you one more come on can't end
like that geez that was disappointing oh
man I had my one good game of the day
it's not gonna happen again it was a
really good game my one good game called
it you didn't call it get out of here
goose is if you get rekt too quick it
doesn't count one more yeah he called
that okay
John Kraft says a rip in advance Thanks
vote of confidence
I might open up the graphics for a sec
people uh people asking about what we're
running at looks like ultra yeah we're
running it at Ultra that's impressive
okay
[ __ ] sure a little bit
more places to run to I guess this is
the run I hope so we shall see
chicken dinners for all
I might go get myself an actual chicken
dinner after this is over
this game ruin chicken dinners for me
I'm kidding all right
one guy at least one guy look around
yeah there's a second guy third fourth
yeah that's fine I I'm not too concerned
with a lot of people land here and a lot
of people landing gak cuts like oh oh
cuz there's what for Billy oh I saw that
guy land over there yeah but chi-chi's
big enough where there's cover like you
don't need to worry about like like
there's enough weapons to go around
right
gube says how I earned it though well no
but I'm hungry tryst would says how do
you get the ghillie suit I've seen in a
few videos I imagine it's a drop right
just been one of those loot crate's yeah
I don't know that that seems interesting
right because the tactical advantage
right a huge advantage I'm feeling today
my or this might be one of those games
where I get more m16 ammo but I know
what to do it
Jesus yeah I guess I'm gonna take it and
go for grip heck yes
Chris Anderson says drop crates from
planes have ghillie suits they're
totally random I've gotten them a bunch
that makes more to make sense yeah I
feel like getting it in a holy cow
well you know as like a potential like
starting equipment it seems like a
really unfair advantage yeah cuz like I
imagine you lay down in grass and that
and it's just like you're no one's gonna
see you
yeah why not put it on disk so I think
there's gonna be on full auto gun scroll
box says the 5.56 mm s jo God use it
this is when people can't find assault
rifles this is where they all are there
are they're all here
they're all right this is actually
boating well right because that means no
one else is gonna get them except for me
don't think that's gonna happen but
seriously that was like six No
I really want the circle to close in on
one of the cities like I feel like that
just oh god that doesn't happen nearly
as much as it should yeah I agree
because I feel like cities would make it
a little bit more interesting on those
final right otherwise just a field a
minute it's really kind of down to dumb
luck of where you landed yeah uh wait
did you do not have a vest there's a
mess back there where uh Toronto I know
oh shoot right like some sights yeah
Chris is saying the ghillie suit is
pretty overpowered because you can just
hide in bushes
you like shotguns I'd rather have two of
these plus that's a double-barrel don't
bear it was great closed so if you hit
him you miss though yeah you're screwed
what GP do you guys have running on this
PC and not sure actually yeah this is
kind of just like the stream PC I don't
really know
I know it is at 1080 Oh GPU yeah GP
would be the 1080 yeah
Oh since the graphics okay I was
thinking yeah me too
give me a sight
I've already been in this building no I
haven't animal for days maybe I should
take the 8k just so I'm not sharing it
yeah I was gonna say what do I switch
though oh man you guys think m416 or the
scar see what chat says I'm not really
in a hurry
switch m16 m416 m4 okay I'll do that I'm
gonna take the extended mag off of it
though
we love that AKO yeah oh my god how did
I miss all this oh yeah put on that red
dot sight
so much ammo
you know there's a lot of people just
hanging out in this town oh yeah they're
just doing what you're doing I mean we
only heard like one firefight
man getting bombed again oh wow
nothing get on
conference Oh God
Jesus it's like something out of a
horror might know that oh my god I don't
think I'm gonna do anything about it I
don't even know if he saw you I don't
think you did
this is unbelievable there there must
not be any assault rifles anywhere else
on this map it has to all be unfortunate
this is like the eighth one okay
nice nice cars moving that way okay
oh nice I don't need to go for his stuff
no that's not like a grenade that yeah
that's something like a grenade I wonder
if that guy that way that guy was just
sitting I wonder if he threw try to
throw a grenade oh would I have gone
through the window yeah oh no all right
all right we're gonna have to call it
that sucks yeah that's pretty good
though
oh no that's not the camera that's
definitely the camera tell your things
broken all right well I'm gonna get back
on the game pip sorry about that folks
the things this camera went to black
thanks everyone for watching this
episode of pub G Mondays normally it's
Jake and Mike but Michaels in here so I
filled in but make sure to come back
next Monday so you can check them out
and then of course we have a ton of
stuff every weekday at 11 a.m.
lobby on Wednesday me and Joey are
starting our new show on Friday which
we're very excited about and I'm sure
Rob and Peter have something cool for
Thursday as well so I'm sure tune in for
that do we have anything cool like video
wise you want to pimp like I mean reboot
went up yesterday
it's about fortnight I'd recommend
checking that out and then you also have
history of Sonic write history Sonic
almost an hour long but well worth it
yeah and then I know you guys are
working on a video I don't know when
it's going up but yeah we're on
something cool yeah keep an eye out for
that stay tuned for that all right
thanks guys see you next time see ya